let's try instead
with tristan in kansas tristan in kansas
you are on the air
hey can you hear me okay yes i can
okay well you kind of pulled a trump
there david because i'm actually in
kansas city missouri yeah it's okay i i
i it all gets truncated so all i could
see was kansas
yeah yeah
so um
going to the situation in ukraine yes
there's a would you say there's a lot of
quote unquote western hysteria about
this because i'm just non-stop getting
bombarded with news articles and
and videos about it and everything but
you know people i'm friend you know
people i talk to in ukraine they're
saying it's it's it's being hysterized
or i don't know the right word for it
yeah
i understand well i think there's a
couple different things going on first
of all
a lot of the discussion around russia
ukraine
is related to russia's role in the world
as one of the three major superpowers
along with china and the us so a ton of
the discussion you know if if there's a
population that's about to be invaded
that population being ukrainians one of
the priorities should be
what's going to happen to ukrainians
what do ukrainians want what is this so
for example
israel is helping to evacuate jews from
ukraine under the belief that if russia
were to invade it's probably not
particularly good for jews that's about
the people
and what's that's being lost
significantly because the context is
putin versus biden and will china take
this as an opportunity to be aggressive
with taiwan or whatever the case may be
it makes sense because these are big
geopolitical players but i do think that
there's kind of a missing element which
is the ukrainian people that's a part of
it
the second part
is i do think that there's significant
politicization here individuals looking
to there are left and right wingers that
are increasingly aligning with
authoritarian regimes like putin there's
an opportunity to call biden weak no
matter what he does and so there's a lot
of political opportunism as well
of course do you do you think there's
an actual possibility of world war three
like a strong possibility in your eyes
or do you think that's hyperbolic do you
think i think that's hyperbolic i think
that's hyperbolic and i know that the
there's you know
um
nato allies are increasingly sort of
preparing and putting troops at the
ready
but i i really don't think this is
something that even if russia were to
invade ukraine
i i have i would bet against this going
anywhere else into any kind of world war
scenario in the immediate five years
from now in a totally different
situation maybe but i don't i think that
that's hyperbolic
yeah it just it's really reminded me a
lot of you know i get really annoyed
when people compare putin to hitler
because
but i i will say that it it does mirror
the beginnings of world war ii a lot
where hitler would annex his you know
the territories and the immediate
surroundings yeah here's the difference
though
here's the difference the world is
completely different than it was in the
world war ii era and as a result both of
different geopolitics technology and by
technology i mean both weapons and
surveillance technology
i don't think that just because there's
something about it that is similar it
means the outcome is going to be the
same these could be famous last words
but i think we have to consider the
context in the world in which this is
happening
yeah exactly that was that was my idea
that i just keep getting bombarded with
articles and fear-mongering so it's been
giving me anxiety this helps a lot i
have friends in europe i talked to about
this too so it's it's good to have
different perspectives and not just be
stuck in like little bubbles but thank
you so much david my pleasure thanks for
the call very very important topic for
sure
uh wow folks the phone lines are packed
today and we're going to be speaking to
a variety of different people why don't
we go next to george in dublin george
you were on the air what's on your mind
today
hi can you uh can you hear me i can
uh okay great um so my question is
actually about ukraine as well
and it's um
given that the us and nato have viola uh
violated their promise from uh from the
90s to not expand eastwards
uh can we release and given that the us
has military bases all over the world
yes can we really say that putin is the
provocateur in this situation
because it seems to me that you know
from a structural perspective
you know uh nato has been provoking
russia for decades by expanding
eastwards i don't buy it no i don't buy
it i mean there's um at a certain point
we have to be able to say well hold on a
second we can do any kind of theorizing
and analysis we want we can we can have
the conversation you're having about
nato
but
you would you you would have to believe
that someone is sort of forcing putin to
mass troops at the border
uh and it just seems like a tough bridge
for me to cross no i don't i don't i
don't think so that's a little bit too
far i'm fine with structural analysis
for sure
but uh
no i don't th that's not striking me as
uh
as something that makes sense to me
i mean i i think i think i certainly
agree that putin is uh is a dishonest
actor okay but it just it um i don't i
don't really think any serious person
could disagree with that but it just
seems to me that
you know from the perspective of the
russian presidents you know what good is
nato's word or the us's word when they
said we're not going to expand eastwards
sure and then
14 eastern countries from countries from
the former eastern bloc get to join nato
you know but you know i think that the
counter still is if putin is massing
troops at the border with ukraine
he may be planning to invade ukraine and
it makes sense to
game out that possibility you know and i
say this as someone who doesn't want any
conflict whatsoever
yeah sure sure definitely um uh by the
way i'm sure you heard but uh justice
breyer um is about to retire so
biden may may have a chance to appoint
someone the supreme court indeed uh so
yeah thanks for taking thanks thanks for
taking my call all right my pleasure
thank you so much for the call very much
appreciate that one of our sponsors is
blinkist who's been supporting the david
pakman show longer than any other
sponsor blinkist is the app that lets
you listen to or read an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist is the way to absorb those
books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below